(cat meowing)
- [Shaun] A lot of people
see a cat up in a tree,
they're just like,
"Oh, yeah, that thing'll get
down here in a couple days."
- [Tom] Hi sweetie, how
long you been in this tree?
But what they don't realize is that
sometimes they don't.
I'm Shaun Sears.
- And I'm Tom Otto with Canopy Cat Rescue.
- And we rescue cats that
get stuck up in trees.
(upbeat music)
(cat meowing)
- [Shaun] There you go, oh, let go.
- Cats get stuck in trees a lot.
- We've been rescuing
since about 2008.
- [Shaun] I'm getting ya.
We probably do more cat rescues
than anybody in the world.
- I got you.
- We range from about
375 to 400 rescues every year.
- [Tom] It's okay.
- There's a lot of people
that can't afford to pay
your normal arborist
five, six, 700 dollars
to rescue a cat.
Both Tom and I really love cats.
- [Tom] He's a total sweetie, ginger boy.
- We'll come out and rescue
somebody's cat for free.
- [Tom] Hi sweetie.
(phone ringing)
- Alright.
Canopy Cat Rescue, this is Shaun.
- [Man] Yeah, it's our cat.
She's climbed up
and she's been up there
for three or four hours
and it just doesn't look like
she's gonna figure this out.
- Well, I think we'll be there in
about 45 minutes or so.
- [Tom] Climbing trees
is inherently risky.
- Our average tree
height is a hundred feet.
Sometimes they're a lot taller.
- [Shaun] We sort of suss out
how the cat's doing as
we're getting close.
- [Tom] Hi.
- [Shaun] And then hopefully
we can proceed with the rescue.
- [Tom] You never want to stay.
How's that sound?
(cat meowing)
- [Woman] Wow!
Good whew.
- [Shaun] The look that we get
from the cat owner's face when we
hand 'em their cat back
is just this overwhelming sense of relief.
- [Tom] Are you happy to have him back?
He's, I know.
- You have no idea .
- [Shaun] We love doing
this and we're gonna do it
for as long as we can.
You said you got a cat stuck in a tree?
- Bella!
- We don't really
consider ourselves heroes,
but we do like to think of ourselves
as just two guys that are out there
restoring the faith in humanity.